[Música]
tostes
tá aí tanto meu nome é mais perigosa
eu sou esse indivíduo a van foi
concebido em 1937 privilégio e sorte ter
os pais maravilhosos que se procurará
deixaram falharam e que diziam também é
intenso sol orgulhosamente só deu certo
a família só a formatura
esta festa é a moda agora é o momento
alto a galera de várias vezes sempre de
melhorias
[Música]
e considero uma pessoa também que agora
fala sério
você considera uma pessoa que adora
desafios e sujrob mas não é
tive que falhar várias ruas e que várias
vezes porque alguém paulo e diz que é
impossível não consegue fazer isso não
criei então fiquei algumas horas a
tentar a tentar até que durante cinco ou
seis segundos atrás com comigo e eu nos
últimos anos tipo 1 uma sorte ou montado
arrisquei falou momento do
empreendorismo um pouco falava e teriam
que enviar currículos trabalhar na
empresa
ian qualidade de lidar com os últimos
anos atentado falhado voltar a aprender
adaptado e voltar a tentar voltar a
falhar tanto esse quanto mais falha mas
se adapta mais aprendo mas tanto quanto
mais rápido este processo
a probabilidade de sucesso estará os
vencidos quando falei na minha tia
aprender mais um pouco
três anos atrás de oportunidade surgiu o
desafio de tentar perceber o que é isto
é solidariedade para a caridade
e porque é que existe cuidado ou ganhar
dinheiro eu não posso ter dinheiro e
vontade eo e porque é que eu fizer
janeiro
olha lá está as pessoas e então surgiu o
desafio de tentar não ter uma coisa ou
outra mas sim uma coisa e outro que as
duas podem potenciar cria e recria com
força aqui e falar que estava falando
essa inovação social e que esta língua
oficial mas primeiro teve a oportunidade
de aprofundar a
vou tentar perceber que a cola reis ou
cola redes vários problemas que existem
atualmente concretizado com solidarizado
nós quisermos chamar e porque grandes
problemas do mundo continuam a ser os
grandes problemas do mundo e esses
problemas são gigantescos em escala
pequena contra esses grandes problemas
nós temos uma espécie de mentalidade
coletiva ou um sistema que mantém
pequenas e vamos a alguns exemplos 90%
todos os fundos angariados por
instituições vão sempre as mesmas 55
instituições 81% das instituições de
solidariedade estão mais preocupadas em
subir em angariar fundos para sobreviver
em vez de combater os problemas pra
focam ou que desviam estar a ficar pode
chover e quando olhamos para os níveis
de pobreza
não temos nenhum problema de 100 para a
áfrica é o índia ano no reino unido
estados unidos em 2% de janeiro a
pobreza e 1970
nada mudou e quando vamos mais a fundo
também no reino unido em ondas a pobreza
infantil está em 30% e sempre esteve no
canadá mas o estudo foi ver o que se
passa aqui a qual é o problema porque
tantos anos
continuamos a tentar combater esses
problemas mas não há
existe um forte processo de novo office
estão um capitalismo versus variava de
uma 11 10
mas é uma diferença a inflamada entre
essas duas indústrias e eu queria
partilhar com força é e há vários
problemas aconteceram cartões para em
três grandes frentes a primeira é a
compensação
desafio vocês querem fazer um donativo
por exemplo uma maior organização ea
opção a uma rendição e sempre sem
resposta coletivo vai para a causa a
opção ver a 60% possa levar à causa 40%
abaixo do chão quente teria a opção a
100 por cento
este problema há muito mais coisas que
estão aí está o problema
como é que nós queremos que uma
instituição grande escala uma estrutura
criminosa ação que invista em tempo e ea
acredita lento se todo o dinheiro vai
vai para a causa e as pessoas que estão
por trás de estrutura da instituição
dessa porcentagem foi para a causa
outro lema mais de 7 entretanto que
quando vemos quando olhamos pra alguém
ou temos uma atitude negativa quando
vemos alguém fazer dinheiro à custa das
pessoas mas é de santos que não temos
falta de negativa do sol faz dinheiro
não é tudo pessoas é f
o segundo risco sabemos que quando vemos
o risco de falha a falha e quando
voltamos à inovação problema do
crescimento e quanto menos o crescimento
não conseguir criar escala para combater
grandes problemas da capital registou no
mundo está tanto na capital quanto
investe no passado nós vamos falhar o
acesso à amazon facebook google o google
talvez não mas neto integrada da orla
campanha sem ter paciência quer passar
vários anos sem faturar recebiam 118 eo
público que já sabia que havia um
objetivo
havia uma visão havia um construir
escala
a uma instituição social criada uma
instituição e disser é preciso dinheiro
para que em cinco anos a tratar pessoas
de fazer coisas de gênio vale
experimentar coisas novas e talvez possa
olhar mas podem andar na linha no
caminho não vai nem para causas que
merecem isso acontecer eles seriam
complicados mas num mundo off line e até
valorizar a falha
outro lema talentos tanto quanto vocês
quando estava na universidade para
trabalhar com a microsoft a google para
de empresas quando trabalhava na prova e
aveiro para personalizar melhor pra mim
o sucesso
quantas cadeiras do empreendedorismo
social problemas no mundo como é tem uma
história português e inglês
como é que nós podemos combater um
problema que nem sequer
estudamos na esquerda dia será o que
irritou o problema é que eu vier uma
instituição
talvez quando nós temos alunos de mba do
mestrado doutoramento a opção vou
trabalhar com uma empresa ou talvez
trabalhar para uma instituição numa
empresa mas desta vez mais numa
instituição
algumas vão fazer com que tal escolher
uma empresa você pode pensar em tamanhos
iguais são gananciosos ganhava dinheiro
querem saber por que eles pegam 2010
mais de 700 dou uma instituição chamada
oscilando
às vezes vão lavar e tal integrou os
conselhos de capital nem ter tempo nem
com sua estrutura numa instituição como
é que consigo conseguir atrair talento
nova novas - querem fora aplicar
tecnologia e tentava criar de corrupção
nesse mercado taxa nada tanto tempo mau
uso da tecnologia
a filha não consegue inovar porque a
indústria não deixa a tanto isso é
resultado de estudo é um tanto os três
grandes frentes fossem aplicadas como é
aplicado mundo foto prof
obrigado a um novo software e serviços
do parlamento
aqui eu acho que não sei e estou à
procura da resposta passa a bola com o
consulado
o importante aqui é que dizer é que
estou aqui a pedir que haja uma
discussão ou na forma como volkswagen
perante este tipo de situações mas sim a
forma como a suspensão após a
mentalidade na mentalidade mais generosa
uma forma de feira esses problemas de
outras perspectivas não achar que o
percentual das coisas evitar julgar só
por áreas fazem dinheiro assim ou
daquela instituição do plano
aí eu disse ou uma grande empresa vem
levando então e e levadas de tentativa
de criticar julgar em vez de perceber e
entender e tentar é um dos grandes
problemas é e eu quero é também o nosso
grande problema não está na nova
tecnologia o sucesso da forma como nós
olhamos para esse problema de nossa
mentalidade é obrigado
[Aplausos]